if you're like us you love all things
Disney but all those happy Disney movies
have a dark side stay tuned to find out
the sad reason why Disney characters
usually don't have parents
I could feel it
Disney movies have given us some of the
most beloved characters of all time
from movies about princesses to films
about talking toys the world of Disney
is absolutely magical nothing can cheer
us up like watching a Disney movie the
characters are relatable and awesome
there's a perfect mix of humor and feel
good vibes and let's not forget - the
awesome soundtracks but almost all
Disney movies have something else
super-important in common they usually
have at least one missing parent and
more often than not the missing parent
is the mother sometimes movies have
killed off both parents and let's not
forget the princess in movies with the
evil stepmothers it's been a
long-running joke that Disney must hate
moms when there are mom figures they
aren't always the healthiest
relationships the why is this the case
well there is one major reason why
Disney characters don't have parents and
there are also some other complicated
ones but first let's take a look at the
characters who are missing one or both
of their parents do people assume all
your problems got solved because a big
strong man showed up yes more than half
of all Disney movies since 1937 have had
an absent parent we'll start with the
princesses when it comes to the Disney
Princess crowd it's actually easier to
say which ones do have parents Aurora
from Sleeping Beauty has two living
parents but she doesn't grow up with
them she lives with the fairies for her
own safety so we aren't sure that really
counts as having parents the same thing
happens with Rapunzel entangled she is
kidnapped as a baby both of her real
parents are alive but she doesn't know
about them until the end of the movie
that leaves us with just three
princesses who do have both parents
present in their lives
Mulan is the first one her parents love
her very much and are very supportive of
course she sneaks off to join the war to
protect her father but she definitely
has the best relationship with two
living parents out of all of the
princesses is it any coincidence that
she's probably the strongest princess
out of the
then there is another super-tough
Princess Merida from brave has two
living parents both her father and her
mother totally adore her but she has a
strained relationship with her mom
then there's Moana who also has both
parents and she goes on to save her
entire culture so what about the rest of
the 14 princesses Snow White and
Cinderella are both missing their mother
and father and they were forced to live
with an evil stepmother Ariel in the
Little Mermaid has a father but no mom
that's also true for Belle Pocahontas
and Jasmine Tiana from The Princess and
frog also has a mom but her father is
gone then there is Anna and Elsa they
have parents at the beginning a frozen
but within the first 20 minutes they are
lost at sea these two princesses are
orphaned at a really young age it's not
just the Disney Princesses though the
missing parent theme is present in a ton
of other Disney movies
Tarzan's parents are tragically killed
by a cheetah at least he gets an awesome
adoptive mom though who cares that she's
a gorilla right lilo and Nani from lilo
and stitch don't have parents anymore
even in Finding Nemo Marlins wife is
killed early on there are missing
parents in Vic hero 6 and brother bear
even goofy in the goofy movie is a
single dad Andy from Toy Story only has
a mom and it's not just the animated
movies Pirates of the Caribbean has
Elizabeth as the character with no
mother and let's not forget the movies
where something bad happens to the
mother Dumbo's mom gets captured and in
one of the saddest moments in all of
Disney history
Bambi's mom is tragically taken from him
we could seriously make a whole video
just listing all the missing parents in
the world of Disney these are just a few
of them there are actually over 30
Disney movies with missing parents well
one of the reasons has to do with Walt
Disney's very own mother your tissues
ready because this is one seriously sad
story so Walt Disney was pretty young
when he became successful he was
animating when he was in his 20s by the
late 1930s he was making lots of
cartoons with his company in 1937 he
released Snow White which was the first
feature-length Disney movie Walt's loved
his family he really adored his parents
and since he had become really
successful he decided to do something
nice for them so he bought them a house
but it turned bad really quickly see
houses used to be heated with gas before
electric heating well some houses still
are but they are a lot safer these days
the house that Disney bought for his mom
and dad had a gas leak when gas leaks it
releases carbon monoxide this invisible
gas has no smell and it is super
poisonous it can make you really sick or
even cause people to pass away these
days houses have carbon monoxide
monitors to tell you if there's a leak
but this was a long time ago the date it
happened isn't super clear some sources
say it was 1938 the year after Snow
White was released others say it was in
the early 1940s
either way this gas leak caused a major
tragedy Disney sent some workers from a
studio out to his parents new house they
tried to fix the gas leak and they
thought they did but they weren't really
experts in the matter so the gas
continued to leak Walt Disney's father
ended up hospitalized from the carbon
monoxide poisoning but his mother wasn't
so lucky
this was a really awful time in Walt's
life he definitely blamed himself
because he bought the house of course we
know it wasn't his fault but he didn't
see it that way he lived with guilt
about it for the rest of his life and he
really didn't talk about what happened
much that's never a good idea it's
important to talk about how you feel
with people who genuinely care for you
poor Walt's we feel so bad for him as a
result of this tragedy he included lost
parents in a lot of his movies this
isn't the only reason why there are so
many missing Disney parents though it's
actually a lot more complicated than
that
and of course Snow White was released
before Walt's mother died depending on
the actual year it happened there might
have been a few more movies with tragic
parents stories like Dumbo so we can't
blame all of it on Disney's own tragic
backstory also Walt Disney passed away
in the 1960s but Disney the company has
been making movies without parents for
decades since then are they doing it
because of Ault Disney's mom that just
doesn't seem realistic another reason
was given by Don han who produced
Maleficent he says that Disney movies
are often coming-of-age stories the
characters need some
to happen that will make them grow up
since Disney movies are usually only
about 90 minutes long they need an easy
way to do this
something major needs to happen either
on screen or off screen to make our main
characters grow up quickly
Disney seems to think the easiest way to
do this is by making them grow up alone
and misguided sure that would make any
character grow up really fast but there
has to be some other way to do it some
people have said that missing parents
are also important to the stories most
Disney characters have some sort of
adventure they also make mistakes that
give us awesome plots a lot of people
pointed out that parents especially moms
keep us from making big mistakes like
that Anne's parents tend to keep us from
going off on big dangerous adventures
but we aren't sure we buy that look at
Mulan having two parents didn't keep her
from running away and saving all of
China just like Mulan Moana leaves her
two parents behind to save her people
and she is one tough princess and Merida
still has two parents the strained
relationship with her mom is what leads
to her adventure there are plenty of
other ways to grow up and have
adventures without throwing missing
parents into the plot other people are
quick to point out that we can't blame
Disney for this trend a lot of Disney
movies were based on fairy tales and
fairy tales have a lot of deceased
parents too fairy tales have been around
for a long time many of the most famous
ones were written by Hans Christian
Andersen and the Brothers Grimm why did
they include so many lost parents well
one reason is the time period when they
were alive people didn't live as long as
they do today there were more orphans
than there are now in developed
countries they just didn't have the
medical knowledge to save people from
illnesses so stories without parents
would have been a lot more relatable
there is also the whole thing about
needing to grow up quickly losing a
parent will do that and it's an easy
thing to write into a short story fairy
tales also talk about the loss of
innocence and childhood and one of the
best ways to show that is through a
metaphor having parents keeps you
innocent and young but if you don't have
them you lose that and when it comes to
storytelling strategies it's not just
fairy tales any type of adventure story
with a hero or heroine needs one
important feature
the hero has to have a tragic backstory
and an easy way to have that happen is
by making the character have a single
parent losing parents makes heroes
relatable even if it hasn't happened to
the reader or audience member Disney is
definitely not the only company that
uses this storytelling feature when Star
Wars was first released it was not a
Disney Company but Luke Skywalker was an
orphan who didn't know the truth about
his parents we also see this trend in
superhero stories
spider-man lost his parents at a young
age and was raised by his aunt and uncle
in the comics batman literally watched
his parents pass away as a young child a
lot of young adult books feature lost
parents Lara Jean Covey and to all the
boys I've loved before has no mom
Katniss Everdeen in The Hunger Games
lost her dad and her mom became a broken
shell of a person
Katniss was a tough heroine because she
had already been providing for her
family
tragic backstories make heroes stronger
because they've already had to overcome
stuff they grow up quickly and are used
to lost that makes their stories much
more effective to the audience and it
obviously works there are so many
stories that have missing parents but it
is still super sad there have to be
other ways for Disney to give us
conflict some of the characters have
proven that a parent doesn't have to die
for there to be a great story and
sometimes we just want to watch a Disney
movie without tearing up but we aren't
sure Disney is going to change up their
habit anytime soon it's been a pretty
successful strategy so far there's a
reason why they are one of the most
successful movie companies ever we would
still like to see more characters like
Mulan Merida and Moana though if you
love Disney as much as we do leave a red
heart emoji in the comment section down
below and be sure to tell us who your
favorite Disney characters are while
you're at it and that's a wrap
give this video a big thumbs up if you
love Disney movies and be sure to
subscribe to the things for more videos
like this one thanks for watching we'll
see you next time
[Music]